Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. Muito boa
noite.
Então, o objetivo dessa live é responder
as perguntas do questionário da
segunda-feira, porque a live que nós
fizemos terça-feira
foi do questionário que eu acabei
repetindo sem querer.
Seja muito bem-vindo, Luig, novo membro
da nossa comunidade.
Seja bem-vindo, Eliseu. Elizabe,
Antônio, Renato, Rosângela, Maria das
Neves
e Irma.
Se eu deixa de falar o nome de alguém
aqui, me perdoe. Bem, vamos começar a
apresentação das perguntas.
Me deem só um instante aqui para eu me
organizar. Eu
acabar de ser acabei de encerrar uma
consulta aqui, por isso que atrasou um
pouquinho também a nossa live.
Deixa eu ver se é esse aqui. Não, não é
esse.
Ou é? Pera aí.
aqui. Pronto.
E de só um instante.
Bem, a primeira pergunta de Mateus.
Quais dosagens pode ser utilizado
Glicinac?
E eu acho que houve aí uma
confusão em relação
à grafia, né? Me parece que a pessoa tá
perguntando de glicina e não de, né? Ou
então é um filhote aí da do casamento da
glicina com bem, vou entender que a
pergunta é sobre a glicina, OK?
A dosag da glicina varia muito de acordo
com o objetivo. Se objetivo for, por
exemplo, dormir bem à noite, a dose por
volta de 3 g à noite, né?
E então essa é a dose padrão para sono.
Se for para aumentar os níveis de
glutationa,
a gente pode trabalhar com doses um
pouco menores. É de 500 mg a 1 g junto
com o NAC. Aí seria o NAC mais glicina,
500 mg de cada,
duas vezes ao dia para aumentar a gluta
tá? Então para sono 3 a 5 g por dia,
mas também pode tomar doses menores para
sono. Tem gente que responde doses
menores.
Então essa que seria a faixa de dosagem.
Bem, é muito seguro a glicina, tá? Tanto
a glicina quanto o nac são muito
seguros.
E se você tem dúvida, começa com 500 mg
por dia, vai subindo aos pouquinhos, tá?
Até chegar a 3 g por dia da glicina. O
NAC também é a mesma situação, só que o
NAC geralmente a gente não passa de
dose máxima do NC geralmente é por volta
de 2400 mg por dia, tá?
Próxima pergunta. Dr. Alan usa o
probiótico abaixo para proteção do
intestino que funciona regularmente.
Lactobacilos acidófilos,
NCFM,
o paracasei LPC37, bifacté animales,
subspécie lactis bif bactérium animal
subspécie lact B07
come brócolis, couve e flor, repolho e
verduras
esse tipo de probiótico pode ser de uso
contínuo.
Bem, essas cepas que você tá usando são
muito boas, são bem documentadas na
literatura,
especialmente o lactobacil para casc
bacterium
animales subspécie lact07.
Ah, mas geralmente a gente pede para as
pessoas fazerem alternância, tá, dos
probióticos.
Mas aqui eu acho que o prebiótico é mais
importante ainda que o probiótico, tá?
Então você tá ingerindo aí alimentos
prebióticos de qualidade que fornecem o
ambiente ideal para as bactérias se
estabelecerem. Então isso já é uma
ótima, tá? Essa conduta à toa de comer
brócolis, repolho, covlor, verduras
escuras, tá?
Não é uma coisa assim proibida você usar
essas cepas aí de uso contínuo, tá? Mas
geralmente a gente pede para as pessoas
fazerem a alternância das cepas, tá?
Mas pode fazer uso contínuo sem pausa,
sem problema nenhum.
Eh, e se você quiser fazer a rotação com
menos frequência, em vez de fazer
rotação a cada 90 dias, fazer cada 6
meses, também é possível.
Mas de novo, o mais importante são as
fibras, tá? Nesse ponto você tem que
ficar mais focado
ou focada.
Qual a sua opinião sobre o uso de
infravermelho, né? Luz infravermelha
para o bem-estar geral é muito bom. É
muito bom, tá? Infravermelho é muito
bom.
É uma ferramenta muito importante para
idosos, especialmente os acamados.
A luz infravermelha próxima, né, da luz
visível, ela funciona em um nível
celular profundo, estimula a atividade
das mitocôndrias, aumenta a produção de
ATP e isso é muito bom para idoso e
especialmente em idosos acamados que t
aquelas lesões por pressão, que a gente
chamava antigamente escaras de decúbito,
né?
Isso por conta da do peso sobre a mesma
região da pele, não tem muita variação
de posição, isso acaba causando essas
úlceras por falta de circulação.
Essa terapia com infravermelho estimula
vaso dilatação, melhora a
microcirculação, reduz inflamação
sistêmica, então ajuda bastante, tá?
Então, eh, em termos assim de frequência
de onda, eu recomendo 660 a 904 nanôm
e aplica especialmente nas regiões de
risco de úlceras de pressão ou escaras
de decúbito, que é a mesma coisa.
E praticamente não tem contraindicações,
tá?
Vale a pena.
Tem um paciente de 74 anos que tinha um
dedímero de 120, repetiu essa semana e
deu 620.
A mudança que houve foi aumento da
atividade física e voltou a usar
cabergulina 05 e tá dada a fila 5.
OK?
A bergulina porque tem tumor de
hipófise, tem proactinoma.
Os outros marcadores inflamatórios estão
normais. Quais seriam as suspeitas desse
caso?
Tá um pouco vago, né?
Tem informação de menos aqui, Patrícia,
fica difícil de eu
opinar, tá? Vamos falar que o aumento do
dedímero tem que ser investigado, tá?
Isso pode ser inflamação, pode ser
infecção, pode ser trombo e pode ser
câncer, tá? São todas as cláusulas de
aumento de dedímero. Infelizmente o
dedímero ele é muito inespecífico. Ele
não é um marcador de trombo só, ele
marcador de inflamação, é um marcador de
câncer, é um marcador de um monte de
coisa, tá?
Então, seria interessante investigar a
trombose venosa profunda,
fazer um traçom dupler venoso das pernas
para investigar esse aumento súbito,
investigar também, talvez um câncer,
verificar se tiver sintoma respiratório,
que pode ser uma embolia pulmonar
assintomática.
OK?
Então, eh, tô tentando ajudar, mas tem
pouca informação aí, tá?
Eh, existe a possibilidade da atividade
física numa pessoa previamente
sedentária ter causado microtraumas
vasculares e ativou o sistema de
coagulação.
E por que que tá tomando cabergolina?
Porque você deu pouca informação aqui,
né?
Se bem que nosso objetivo aqui das lives
não é disculão de caso clínico a nível
de profissional de saúde, tá? Eh, não
foi essa a intenção quando eu criei os
grupos, né?
pede marcadores tumorais,
investiga o ultrassom das pernas,
ultrassom dupler venoso,
revisa todo histórico clínico para saber
se tem alguma situação aí que justifique
esse aumento do dedímero, tá bom?
Porém, você me deu pouca informação para
trabalhar, tá?
Tudo bem. Queria saber, por favor, estou
usando o azul de metilena, peso 58 kg.
Qual seria a quantidade administrada
nesse caso? Cara, eu prefiro
simplificar. Eh, o pessoal se confunde
muito com o azul de metilen em gotas,
não consegue fazer conta direito, fica
tudo confuso, erra dose. O que eu tô
sugerindo pras pessoas é usar os de
metilen em cápsula na faixa aí de 30 a
50 mg por dia. Simplifica muito, tá? Eu
não acho que vocês se confundem muito
com essa coisa de diluição de de gota.
Eh, não acho uma boa paraa maioria das
pessoas, não, tá? Queria suplementar
iodo iodeto, qual seria a sua indicação?
Bem, depende. Você tem rashimoto, usa em
micrograma. Se não tem rashimoto, com
certeza você pode até usar na dose de da
solução de lugol lá, né? Tá bom?
Vamos lá. Mas vamos falar da diluição do
azul de metilen em gotas que eu não acho
uma boa, tá? O PA 1%.
Se você quiser usar 1 mg por kg, seria
58 mg até mais ou menos 116 mg. Mas é
geralmente eu tenho passado entre 30 e
50 mg de azul de metileno, tá?
Mas se você tiver usando em gotas, você
poderia estar usando equivalente aí a 2
a 5 ml da solução.
Isso para questões terapêuticas
do dia a dia, não? Por exemplo, se fosse
uma intoxicação com monóxo de carbono,
seria uma dose completamente diferente,
tá? Uma dose mais alta.
Eu
gosto de trabalhar na faixa de
microgramas do iodo, tá? Mas se se você
tem certeza absoluta que você não tem
rashimoto, você poderia estar utilizando
aí mais ou menos 6 mg por dia da
combinação de iodo e iodeto. Eu prefiro
dar na faixa de 500 microg por dia.
OK.
Fiz um teste de glicemia uma hora após
três refeições, todas com 900 g.
Na cesta, só frutas, banana,
manga, goiaba, mamão, maçã e melão.
Glicemia 108. No sábado, batata doce,
abóbora inhame, farinha de jejelim,
glicemia 112. Domingo só churrasco com
carnes gordas, glicemia 97.
A proteína foi a que menos causou pico.
É lógico que é o esperado, sem dúvida,
tá? Afinal de contas, a aminoácido para
virar glicose muito mais trabalhoso
metabolicamente do que os as outras
fontes que você tá falando aí, tá?
Esses valores são totalmente esperados.
Não tem nada de estranho nesses valores
não,
porque assim, entre os aminoácidos que
compõe a proteína da carne, alguns deles
são glicogênicos e outros não são, né? E
mesmo sendo glicogênicos, o organismo
tem que fazer muito esforço metabólico
para transformar aminoácido em glicose.
Então, é óbvio que a proteína animal vai
ter um impacto menor na glicemia e o
carboidrato, mesmo que não seja
refinado, vai ter um impacto maior.
OK. Não sei se
o que você quis perguntar é isso mesmo.
Não sei se eu entendi o teor da sua
pergunta.
Eu tô fazendo agora, não sei se vocês
estão acompanhando, mas eu tô com
medidor de cetose no braço aqui. É um
medidor de cetose contínua. Eu nem sabia
que isso existia. Na verdade parece que
tá chegando no Brasil. E aí a Andrea
Torres que eu encontrei lá em Portugal,
ela me deu um desses medidores. Eu
comecei a fazer hoje a dieta cetogênica,
tá? Vocês terem uma ideia, eu acordei
hoje de manhã,
eu não estava em jejum porque quando eu
instalei o sensor e demora uma hora para
acordar, digamos assim. Quando eu comi o
meu café da manhã, que foi ovos,
tomate,
eh,
não foi, não foi manjericão, não foi.
Eu coloquei em cima do ovo, foi
orégano
e também um café sem açúcar. A minha
glicemia, glicemia não, desculpa, minha
cetose nesse horário tava 05.
E depois a minha cetose só diminuiu ao
longo do dia, apesar que eu almocei só
carne moída com couve e tomate
e um pou bem pouquinho de feijão.
E eu acho que vou demorar uns três a qu
dias para entrar em cetose mesmo.
Doutor, qual a sua opinião sobre
desparasitar regularmente para
manutenção da saúde? Tá, isso é um tema
bem polêmico, tá? Eu prefiro bom senso.
Eu acho que existe uma linha aí que eu
não concordo, que acha que o parasita é
a causa de todos os problemas do mundo,
até dos impostos altos. É o a culpa do
parasita. Eu acho exagerado isso. A
gente tem que entender que o parasita
também faz parte, alguns, né, fazem
parte do microbioma
ou do bioma nesse caso, porque alguns
parasitas são grandes, né, não são
microscópicos.
Eu penso que tem que fazer pararatização
cada 6 meses.
E o alguns parasitas eles são
interessantes para treinar o sistema
imunológico, deixar ele alerta em
prontidão.
Então, eh, tem estudos interessantes
sobre isso. Então, e essa história que
pessoal pensa que parar de ter culpa
culpado de câncer, culpado de não sei o
quê, culpado de não sei o quê.
Quando você faz paratização, a tendência
o parita voltar uma semana depois. Eh,
alguns parasitas voltam uma semana
depois, tá? Então, eu não sou desses fã
desses protocolos de disparacisação
super complicados
mesmo. O protocolo da Ruda Clark, ele é
bem interessante, mas porque ele tem
várias substâncias muito legais ali pra
saúde, tá?
Mas tome cuidado com esse pessoal aí que
diz que parasita é culpado de tudo.
Alguns parasitas eles vão ajudar no
sistema imune. Eles aumentam o
secretório que é bom para proteger você
contra agentes mais agressivos.
Eles previnem hiperativação do sistema
imune. Tem muitas crianças, por exemplo,
que hoje tem alergia quando nasce porque
não teve exposição alguns parasitas.
Então eles treinam o sistema imune, tá,
para evitar alergias e doenças
autoimunes.
Então tem que pensar nisso.
Então fazer a cada se meses e fazer
quando tiver sintomas, tipo diarreia
prolongada, plurido, anal, perda de peso
sem explicação, exame de férias
alterado, que tem que fazer várias
amostras para poder aparecer.
OK? Ou se tá com fadiga crônica, vale a
pena fazer também.
Essa é minha opinião.
Gostaria de saber sobre suplementos que
eu posso usar com protocolo coimbra para
doença de cron. Não uso medicamentos,
estou em remissão. Todos os exames de
sangue estão ótimos. Parabéns. Mas o
exame de calprotectina continua
alterado.
Passa o protocolo há 6 meses. Bem, para
quem faz o protocolo Coimbra já faz todo
o pacotão lá de nutrientes. Eu não sei
com quem você tá fazendo, mas já era
para ser parte do seu protocolo, que
seria vitaminas em geral, né?
Polivitamínico própolis é importante.
O magnésio também seria isso que você
faria junto aí com protocolo Coimbra.
Ômega-3 é importante também, tá? Então é
isso, ômega-3, polivitamínicos em geral,
própolis e multivitamínico.
Você pode usar também glutamina 5 a 10 g
por dia para ajudar a regenerar o
epitélio intestinal, que também ajuda no
sistema imune. O zinco ajuda no sistema
imune. A cúrcuma, cúrcumina também
ajuda.
E tem ação local no intestinal contra
cron, isso tá documentado em literatura.
Probióticos de qualidade com múltiplas
cepas também podem ajudar,
porque você sabe que o pessoal que tem
crom geralmente tem disbiose.
Lembrando de fazer a restrição de
cálcio, corretamente, porque o protocolo
de vitamina D em altas doses faz você
aumentar muito a absorção de cálcio e
tem que tomar muito cuidado para não ter
calcificação de partes moles ou
nefrocalcinose.
Faz o teste da vitamina D sangue com
diluição para ver a dose. VO paraatormô
PTH, que tem que estar na faixa mais ou
menos do limite inferior no protocolo de
vitamina D em altas doses.
A berberina é interessante tanto pela
ação
antiinfecciosa dela, antidiarreica,
quanto o efeito que ela tem
imunomodulatória e também de regulação
da MPK e da glicose sanguínea, tá bom?
Seria esses que eu te recomendaria.
Eu
e meus pais tomamos duas cápsulas de
ômega3
mega DHA por dia. Cada
cada você tá, vamos lá. Deve ter deve
ser por dia cada. Tá. Ponto. Você
recomendou na live passada que para
tomarmos um com outro tipo.
Recomenda um em específico desse outro
tipo de ômega-3? É o EPA. É o EPA, é o
ômega-3, tem o EPA e DHA, tá? Então você
pode tomar o rico em DHA junto com o
outro que é o normal, que não é rico em
DHA. É isso, tá bom? Se uma pessoa tomar
omôme 3 de noite, de manhã tomar de
novo, isso pode causar coágulos por
excesso? Não. O ômeega-3 não causa
coágulo, é o contrário. Ele pode tornar
o sangue fluido demais ou fino demais,
tá? Não é coágulo, você confundiu. Então
se você tomar muito ômega-3, tipo seis
cápsulas, oito cápsulas por dia, você
pode ter um problema aí de sangramento,
tá? Isso não é comum, mas é possível.
Tá bom, ficou claro? Você tá ao vivo?
Tá sim. Antônio, Renato que fez a
pergunta.
Depois você me responde se você entendeu
a explicação.
Você junta os dois, o que tem rico em DH
com o rico em EPA, que é o mais comum,
tá?
Então, em relação ao vitafor, você tem o
ômega3 EPA regular. Aí você pode estar
usando ele junto com esse rico em DHA,
por exemplo, você pode alternar. Um dia
você toma duas capsulas do rico em DHA,
o outro dia você toma duas cápsulas do
rico em EPA, fica alternando, tá bom?
Bem, vamos paraa próxima.
Sou médico, estou no grupo há pouco
tempo, inclusive tô recebendo umas
mensagens de uns médicos entrando no
grupo, né? E o pessoal tá querendo que
eu converse mais dentro da
complexidade maior, né?
Eu tô analisando essa situação. Vamos
lá. Sou médico, estou no grupo há pouco
tempo, já aprendi bastante, mas aplico
apenas em minha saúde por enquanto. Onde
ficam as referências biográficas? Então
eu todos os vídeos que eu faço eu coloco
as referências. Quer dizer, quando eu
lembro, né, às vezes acontece de eu
esquecer porque essa correria de
fazneio,
faz título, faz três tipos de fnei três
tipos de título e aí às vezes eu esqueço
de colocar as referências, tá?
E há um grupo só para médicos por
enquanto não, tá?
Sou mãe de dois, moro no Paraná, até
pretendo fazer nutrologia ou
integrativo, homeopatia, mas já fiz
quatro pós e atuo há 30 anos e é difícil
fazer online. Então eu vou colhendo
conhecimentos onde posso. Muito grata.
Gosto muito das suas aulas e também dos
vídeos. Obrigado. Envio inclusive para o
grupo de WhatsApp do Conselho Municipal
da Saúde. Opa, não vai me arrumar
problema
aqui pros leigos assistirem. Obrigado
pela gentileza. Tá bom.
Bem, eu vou pensar seriamente nisso, é
porque assim, eu agora tô sendo muito
mais chamado para Congresso, tá? Então,
a tendência vai ser chamar atenção mais
do pessoal que é médico mesmo, porque o
que aconteceu nos últimos anos é que o
meu nome tá bem estabelecido entre os
leigos, mas os colegas muitos a muitos
deles não me conhecem ainda, então eu
não tenho um nome tão bem estabelecido
entre os colegas, mas a tendência
vai ser isso mudar. E eu já tô
planejando, tá, uma assinatura
mensal que você vai ter acesso às minhas
aulas mais sofisticadas paraa área de
saúde mesmo. Eu tô montando a
plataforma. A razão de que eu não tô com
isso pronto ainda, é porque eu tive
muito problema já no passado com
plataforma da Hotmart,
com a Julivi
também tive com plenitude. Então eu
decidi que eu vou ter que fazer um
negócio totalmente meu, sabe?
dá mais trabalho, mas no meu caso vai
ser a solução, tá? Então, viu,
Adriane? Espere por novidades. Eu vou
divulgar e vai ser um um valor muito
acessível, tá? Eu não vou eu não vou
cobrar horrores de dinheiro pro pessoal
entrar, não. Então, fique tranquila, não
saia do grupo que vale a pena para você.
Isso aprende muita coisa e se você fizer
as perguntas aí mais técnicas, eu vou me
eu vou responder dentro do do nível de
complexidade que você quer, mas eu vou
vou me dá no máximo dois meses que eu
vou ter com essa plataforma no ar, tá?
Porque eu eu passei a parte gráfica de
fazer o o a landing page para uma pessoa
porque não tava com tempo de fazer isso
e ela tá dando uma enrolada, tá? Mas
assim que tiver pronto eu vou te avisar,
OK?
Nós vamos eh tá fazendo esse produto em
breve, tá bom? Vai ser uma assinatura
que a pessoa vai pagar semanalmente e
vai ter acesso a todos meus minhas aulas
mais científicas,
que é mais pra área de saúde mesmo. E
toda semana eu vou estar introduzindo
material lá. Enquanto a pessoa tiver
pagando mensal, vai ter acesso a todo o
conteúdo.
Ah, próximo.
Dr. Alan, o que acontece quando da
ferritina só sobe mesmo tomando
suplementos e fitoterápicos específicos?
Quais são os exames complementares para
se chegar a um diagnóstico? Claro, sei
que precisa de um médico acompanhando
bem a ferritina subindo constantemente
pode ser basicamente ou inflamação que
tá piorando ou uma mulher, por exemplo,
que parou de menstruar e tá acumulando
ferro, tá?
Exame. Você tem que fazer todos os
exames de metabolismo do ferro para
saber se isso é uma ferritina da doença
crônica ou se é acúmulo de ferro
simples, né?
Na maioria das vezes isso é um processo
inflamatório
e não sobrecarga de ferro. Mas em mulher
que já tá na menopausa pode ser
sobrecarga de ferro, sim. Então tem que
investigar a esteatose hepática,
ultrassom de abdômen para avaliar a
quantidade de gordura no fígado. Tem que
ver se não tem uma síndrome metabólica
com aumento de triglice, de glicose, de
de circunferência abdominal,
aumento do LDL colesterol
de marcador de função hepática,
ver se não tá tendo consumo excessivo de
álcool, se não tem uma doença autoimune
não diagnosticada que pode elevar a
ferritina.
Também tem que avaliar a transferrina, o
ferro total,
tá? a capacidade de saturação, tudo isso
tem que ser avaliado, exames de
metabolismo ferro, tá?
Então vamos lá. Saturação de
transferrina. Se tiver acima de 45%
pode ser uma cromatose, que é uma dança
genética. enzimas hepáticas,
eh, potência relativa, VHS,
tá bom? Isso tem que ser feito em
consultório médico, com avaliação do
médico aí.
Espero que você tenha conseguido
entender. Foi a Margarida que fez a
pergunta. Não sei se você tá ao vivo
agora, Margarida.
Dr. Alan, eu votei para que tivesse a
live sobre pornografia e telas, tá? Eu
já coloquei isso no material da próxima
live do domingo, tá? A gente vai ter a
live do próximo domingo. Alguém
perguntou aí, mas eu não soltei o link
ainda, tá? Eu vou fazer o link ainda e
mas já tá preparado todo o material
dessa live,
a próxima super live aí que vocês estão
chamando de super live aí que vai ser no
domingo que vem.
Mas vamos continuar sua pergunta aqui.
Não sou inscrito ainda na comunidade
Super Live. Tá, mas aí tu tem que ir lá
no no YouTube clicar em seja membro e
mudar a tua categoria, tá? Vou me
inscrever. Peço por favor que o senhor
não desconsidere meu volta. Não, eu não
tô nem vendo quem é que tá no quem quer
quem não tá. E alguém falou que só podia
votar quem tava na comunidade. Eu acho
que faz sentido,
mas eu não tenho um jeito de ver isso
agora, tá?
Mas já tá incluído, tá? Eu vi que a
maioria votou a favor, eu incluí na na
live do domingo que vem, tá?
Acredito que os outros também, a maioria
voltou pela live. Sim, voltaram sim.
Fica tranquilo que eu farei e nós vamos
tocar nesse assunto, tá bom?
Vamos paraa próxima aqui,
Dra. Alan, qual a técnica,
tecnologia você usou para fazer com que
todos seus vídeos tivessem tópico sem
ser manual? Ah, meu amigo,
que você achava mais chato? chato,
porque eu tinha que entrar vídeo por
vídeo, puxar todo a transcrição do
vídeo, jogar na IA, mandar a IA e eh eh
fazer a categorização toda lá do dos
tópicos e depois eu tinha que fazer para
uma outra IA para fazer a transformar em
perguntas e respostas, entendeu? Era
muito manual isso daí, tá? Porque tinha
muito vídeo já na comunidade fechada.
Então eu criei uns scripts, eu criei uns
scripts de Python para fazer isso para
mim, simples assim, entendeu?
Eu sou muito nerd mesmo.
Tem um YouTube que fala de teologia, eu
sigo ele e dei a ideia para ele, pois eu
vi que o senhor conseguiu ser sem ser
obrigado a fazer manual. Eu fiz os os
scripts em Python para isso, entendeu?
Compartilha seu conhecimento. Aí você tá
ah me apertando sem abraçar, né? Não é
bem assim, querido. Não é bem assim.
Isso é uma coisa que é só paraa ner que
gosta de informática, viu? Não é simples
assim não.
Pergunta para esse
youtuber aí que você tá falando se ele
gosta de vibe coding, tá? Aí a gente
pode tentar conversar,
mas se ele não tiver muito material, ele
pode fazer bandal. Igual eu fiz no
começo, tá bom?
De novo a história da galinha. Caraca.
Vamos lá, doutora Dutra. Eu crio 12
galinhas e que eu vou ver a galinha
logista desse jeito, cara. Toda toda
semana tem uma pergunta de galinha.
Eu crio 12 galinhas e um que tal. Quero
criá-las de forma caipira, mas eu fiquei
desmotivado com você dizendo que é
perigoso para quem cria. Não, é perigoso
ficar muito próxo da janela que você me
perguntou, né? E para os vizinhos, 3 m
de distância, tem um poço de 72 m de
profundidade, só 4 m tem tubo. Existe
perigo real de contaminação da água?
Como é que é? Pera aí, vamos lá.
Tem um posto de 72 m de profundidade
e só 4 m tem tubo. Eu não entendi só 4 m
tem tubo.
Os muros t 1,80 m de altura.
E se eu fizer um cercado em área de 13
m²,
sendo três lados de muro, chão de terra,
cobrir metade com telha bem fechada para
impedir água e tentar conter mosquito em
altura, metade além da gente, vocês não
gostam de pontuação. Que que vocês tm
contra a pontuação?
E altura, metade, além da tela de arame,
colocar a tela de mosquito acabaria com
um perigo para os vizinhos.
ou acha que não,
que é perigoso de qualquer jeito e mesmo
que não seja perigoso
para os vizinhos, mas de qualquer forma
contamina o poço.
Vamos lá, vamos tentar ajudar aqui,
tá? Vamos lá. O poço de 72 m, me parece
que ele tá protegido contra contaminação
pela profundidade, tá?
Eh, a maioria dos poços que são
contaminados aí por agentes infecciosos,
como salmonela,
no caso por criação de aves, isso
acontece quando tem uma gestão
inadequada dos dejetos dos bichos, né,
que podem filtrar no lençol freático,
mas isso é mais comum para poço raso,
não é o seu caso, tá?
As medidas que você comentou aí de
cercado com cobertura de telha, tela,
piso de terra bem drenado são sim
adequados para evitar o acúmulo de
umidade, proliferação de bactéria.
O ponto crucial não é a cobertura contra
mosquito, mas sim impedir que a água da
chuva e os dejetos se acumulem,
infiltrem no solo.
Então, se você tomar essas medidas aí
adequadas, eu creio que o risco pros
vizinhos é bem
limitado ou praticamente eliminado,
porque a contaminação cruzada vai
acontecer por falta de higiene pessoal
após o contato com as aves ou dispersão
dosjetos contaminados.
E se você tá fazendo o manejo correto
dos dejetos, eu acredito que o risco é
muito baixo, tá? se você faz a limpeza,
a compostagem
e pelo fato do poço ser fundo, não vai
contaminar a água, né?
Então, estrutura de 13 m² com três lados
de muro e cobertura parcial pode ser o
suficiente. Aí
só tome cuidado de lavar bem as mãos
após cuidar das galinhas, separar as
ferramentas e os sapatos pro galinheiro,
fazer a limpeza regular,
OK?
Drenar corretamente os dejetos por uma
composteira. Usa uma composteira, dá uma
estudada em composteira, tá bom? E deixa
ela afastada da área dos do poço.
Isso vai eliminar o risco de
contaminação, tanto para vizinhos quanto
para a tua água.
Não desista das suas galinhas, tá? Elas
estão contando com você.
Desculpa, pessoal, eu tô brincando um
pouco aqui, mas eu tentei ajudar da
melhor forma possível.
Quais são os melhores suplementos para
LDL oxidado padrão B? Interessante a
pergunta, hein?
Bem, o coenzima que é 10 é bem
interessante.
Ostto alfalipoico é também
bem interessante, é um dos melhores
antioxidantes que tem. O próprio PQ
promove biogênesia mitocondrial
e mas tem efeito antioxidante, o
resveratol também.
Asta chantina, o selênio que faz parte
aí da enzimas antioxidantes,
especialmente aí da
das mitocondriais, tá? E o betacaroteno.
Então você poderia estar juntando com
enzima Q10 com alfa alipoico e magnésio
na forma queelada. Isso seria uma boa
opção para reverter ou evitar do LDL
oxidar.
Seria bom usar o ômega-3 também, que
ajudaria nesse ponto aí. Ômega-3 de
qualidade, tá com predominância de EPA.
Não se esquecendo da dos hábitos
saudáveis de vida
e dos alimentos antioxidantes, né?
Beterraba, muito bom, romã, frutas
vermelhas,
né?
os crucíferos, né, como nós falamos,
couve e flor aqui, couve de bruxelas,
brócolis, tá bom?
É possível que ou hasta quecetina com
bromelaína possam causar reações
inflamatórias? Não, reações
inflamatórias não. Pode acontecer reação
alérgica, né? Mas taxantina, na verdade,
é um excelente antioxidante, mas existe
possibilidade de alguém desenvolver uma
reação alérgica.
E os estudos mostram que a sachantina é
um dos anti oxidantes mais poderosos que
existem, né? Ele bloqueia a ativação NFK
beta, reduz a produção de citocinas
inflamatórias como fator de necrose
tumoral alfa e teleocina 6.
Ativa a via NRF2,
que fortalece sistemas de saúde
naturais,
pode ter efeitos colaterais como
qualquer coisa.
Se tiver em altas doses, que difícil ter
porque é caro, né? Seria dor de
estômago, diarrei ause, é possível.
Quecetina, eu acho maravilhoso também,
um ativo caro. Bromelaína com quecetinas
são muito boas, como antiinflamatórios,
antioxidantes.
Existe, lógico, possibilidade de
alergia. Eu não me lembro de ter visto
um caso de alergia com quecetina, mas é
possível.
Tá bom? Então eu acho bem improvável.
Meu filho tem 41 anos, aparentemente
saudável, no momento está trabalhando
com motorista de aplicativo, vem se
queixando já há alguns meses senti
vontade
muito emergente de urinar.
Entendi que poderia ser. É porque ele
fica dirigindo o dia inteiro, tá? deve
estar segurando o xixi muito tempo e aí
segura até o último minuto, né? E aí
quer urinar com urgência. Eu acho que o
mais provável é isso, tá?
Mas pode ser que ele tenha uma bichiga
hiperativa, né? Que é eh em homens é
menos comum do que em mulheres, mas
existe, né? Ele pode estar com uma
infecção crônica e uma prostatite
crônica e não tá sabendo. Ele pode ter
um diabetes controlado, não tá sabendo.
Pode ser que ele tá gordinho, né? Porque
ele tá muito parado dentro do carro e tá
comendo sua porcaria. Então isso é
possível.
A própria ansiedade e o estresse ficar
dirigindo o dia inteiro, né? também pode
estar interferindo nessa urgência
mixcional,
dependendo da posição que ele fica
dentro do carro, se o banco é
confortável ou não, ele pode estar tendo
uma compressão pélvica também, tá? E
isso pode provocar também retenção
urinária por causa da compressão
nervosa.
Então tem que fazer uma avaliação com o
médico, fazer exames, teste de glicemia
de jejum, insulina de jejum, hemoglobina
glicada, ver exame de urina um,
urocultura,
a avaliação das vias urinárias por
ultrassom,
rever a alimentação dele para ver se não
tá comendo muita tranqueira, muito pão,
muito açúcar, muito suco doce, tá?
ou alimentos processados,
industrializados.
Tá bom? Dá uma olhada. Tudo isso tá aí,
tá? De preferência agenda com
urologista.
Olá, doutor. Obrigado por sua valiosa
contribuição. Ajuda a todos.
Para fígado com esteatose 3 indo paraa
cirrose não alcoólica. O que fazer?
Qual o vitâmero da vitamina Eus?
tocotrenois duruc sementes para isso.
Alfalipôico, fosfo decolina,
tá? Tem várias coisas que atuam nesse
ponto aí. tira os alimentos
inflamatórios dele, põe para fazer
atividade física para emagrecer,
pode usar ANAC também, que é muito bom
para isso.
Pode estar usando berberina para
emagrecer, ajudar a emagrecer,
se ele tá acima do peso, né, que deve
tá.
Pode pensar até em usar uma dessas novas
aí, né? Semaglutida, liraglutida ou até
a tizepatida,
apesar de serem polêmicas, né? Tem esses
casos raros aí de cegueira ou de
alteração sexual momentânea,
mas se usar pouco tempo com mudança de
estilo de vida, eu acho que tá valendo.
Os melhores tocotruenóis é o gama e o
delta tocotruenois, tá? Que tem no
urucum, tá? Mas pode estar tomando os
oito vitâmeros também. tem grande
capacidade de proteção do fígado.
Pode usar curcumina também, pode usar
magnésio, ô3,
já falei do NAC, tá? E acompanhar esse
processo todo através da elastografia
hepática, né, que para ver se tá
evoluindo com fibrose ou não, tá bom?
Isso tem que ser feito a cada três ou
seis meses, dependendo do caso.
O senhor poderia explicar a diferença
entre artrite e artrose? Qual é a
etiologia da artrose? É assim, artrite
geralmente é infecciosa, tá? Ou
reumatológica. a gente usa o termoartite
quando tem uma infecção ou tem uma
doença autoimune provocando a
inflamação. E artros geralmente a gente
usa esse termo quando se trata de
desgaste pela idade ou pelo uso
excessivo. Deu para entender a
diferença?
Tá? Então, enquanto que a artrite pode
ser infecção ou processo inflamatório
crônico por doença autoimune, a artrose
geralmente é degeneração progressiva da
cartilagem por uso excessivo,
tá? Ou por trauma ou por idade também,
tá? As cláusulas da artrose eh
envelhecimento, predisposição genética,
pode ser excesso de peso também, lesões
repetidas, excesso de uso, movimentos de
alto impacto. Tudo bem?
Então essa que é a diferença
em relação à prevenção e tratamento,
eh, justamente você ter fortalecimento
de músculo previne lesão de artrose.
Você ter o movimento com mecânica
correta, evitar lesões de esforço de
repetição, né, as chamadas layers, tá?
Isso evita também a artrose.
Alimentação sem açúcar, farinha ou
alimentos inflamatórios previne.
otimizar o peso corporal previne,
fortalecer a musculatura
estabilizadora, como já falei, ingestão
de ômega3, magnésio, colágeno, colágeno
especialmente duralizado, tipo dois,
glucosamina, condroitina,
o DMSO, o MSM, são todas coisas
excelentes para juntas, tá? Vitamina D
também, K2, tá?
O pé, pommito tanulamina, são todas
substâncias interessantes. Aí
o senhor falou que quem tem rachimoto
não pode tomar lugol,
né? É, é minha opinião, tá? É lugol na
dose que o pessoal usa aí, tá? Em gotas
poderia tomar outro tipo de é o que eu
já expliquei no vídeo. Vocês não vê meus
vídeos, gente. Eu expliquei lá no vídeo
isso daí. Iodo e micrograma. Você pode
pegar iodeto de potássio, tá?
na faixa de 300 microg e o iodo
molecular na faixa de 200 junto os dois
dá 500 microg você toma isso daí aí você
toma selênio junto tá bom como se faz o
diagnóstico hashmot através do da
combinação do exame de sangue que vê os
anticorpos antitiroidianos que é o antig
antitiroglobulina e antitiroperoxidase
e ultração dupla de tióide que vê
aumento de circulação arterial na
tirioide sugestiva de tiroidite. São
esses os exames, tá bom?
Então é, esses são os exames para
diagnósticoto. Lembrando que tem que
fazer o exame também de TSH, T4 livre,
T3 livre ou T3 reverso em muitos casos,
tá?
Então é isso aí.
Bem, essa foi a última, né? Vamos ver o
que que Eliseu tá falando lá. Vamos lá.
Eliseu deve est perguntando tudo agora
aqui. Vamos ver. Vamos ver.
Ah, vamos ver se se eu deixo o Eliseu
feliz hoje. Óleo de semente é o
principal culpado pelos casos de câncer
de pele. Azeite de de oliva que são
misturados com esses olhos podem causar
câncer.
Não poderia dizer que o óleo de semente
de soja, por exemplo, milho,
girassol, não é o principal causa de
câncer de pele, na minha opinião, não,
tá? Mas sim, tem que trocar pelo de
olivem, na minha opinião, ou óleo de
coco e outras gorduras mais naturais.
O tratamento de espuma para variz deixa
manchas? Depende. Às vezes sim, às vezes
não, tá? Depende do dos cuidados que
a o profissional toma na hora de fazer a
espuma. D Ana Paula, se tiver aí, ela
pode responder melhor ainda.
De todas as dietas que existem, low
carab, mediterrânea, vegana, a dieta que
emagrece mais rápido é a dieta
carnívora? Não depende. Se a pessoa
comer carne demais, pode ser que não
emagreça tanto assim, não. E a atividade
física que emagrece mais rápido é
calistenia.
Depende, Eliseu, muito dependente de
cada pessoa. Para algumas pessoas, a
dieta que vai emcer mais rápido é
vegana. Para as outras vai ser low fet,
não vai ser low carb. Isso é muito
individual, tá? Infelizmente as pessoas
são diferentes uma das outras ou
felizmente, tá?
Olha, eu acho interessante calistenia,
mas se a pessoa tiver muito pesada, a
calistenia pode ser ruim, porque pode
gerar lesão na pessoa, tá? a lesão
articular. Então, tem que tomar um certo
cuidado.
Ah, eh, eu, eu vou colocar o link do da
live do domingo, tá?
Eh, mais tarde para vocês. Não fiquem
ansiosos, não, tá?
O que funcionaria muito bem pro padrão
não diper, onde a pressão material cai
10% durante sono.
Cara, principal coisa aqui seria
gerenciamento estresse, tá? Essa é a
principal causa dessas pressões altas
noturnas aí.
Aí eu estaria poderia estar utilizando
eliteanina
para ajudar a dar sacar uma focada e e
cair essa pressão arterial junto com com
enzima que é 10 alfa lipoico. São coisas
que ajudam na pressão alta.
Tana Paula está aqui. Olha só,
eu não gosto de trabalhar com
os mettidas no Gotas, não.
Integritar, Viviane, Integritar. O
pessoal conhece aí do grupo, pergunta no
grupo que eles vão te dar o É integritar
com dois TS, tá? Integritar com 2 T.
Ã, lítio orotato no Ierb, mas eu olhei
hoje realmente só tinha as patato de
lítio. Olha no site da Lifextension.
Lifeextension.com.
É, não tem na manipulação não, tá?
Aí, aí a Dora escreveu integritar e a
Biogalênicos também, né?
É, nem sempre é de procedência duvidosa,
não, tá? Mas eu entendo que tá dizendo.
Tem que tomar muito cuidado mesmo.
Por antes.
Não conheço esse site. Depois você vai
ter me falar que site é esse.
Não seja radical. Mercado Livre pode ter
bons fornecedores também, tá? Ahã.
Seja muito bem-vindo, Carlos Henrique. A
nossa
fazendo trocadilho com seu nome. Nossa
Gregória, né?
É Gregória que fala.
E posso pode ser que eu esteja falando
errada.
Eh, eh, eu acho que é Gregória, né, que
fala, né, que quando você junta um grupo
de pessoas com afinidade, a gente pode
chamar de de agrégora.
Agora não, depois eu olho isso aí porque
vem do grego isso daí, se eu não me
engano. Ah, mas seja bem-vindo, viu,
Carlos Henrique?
Ã,
a Paula também tava sabendo do meu da
minha questão com Python aí.
Ah,
e Rush Dun Brasil, ele tem muitos vídeos
manual.
Não entendi.
Ó aí, ó. Dra. Paula escrevendo as coisas
que eu falei durante a live aí.
E cosa corda biobalance
é uma mistura de ômega-3 com com enzima
Q10, se eu não me engano.
Pronto, ela escreveu as coisas aí.
A tua pergunta, qual é que a tua
pergunta? Não, já não respondi.
Ah,
gente, eu já mostrei como é que faz
isso, que vocês querem que eu mostre em
tempo real. Vamos lá.
Deixa eu fazer um negócio aqui.
Deixa eu abrir o Chrome. Eu vou entrar
numa outra conta minha do Google.
Eu vou tentar fazer isso ao vivo, tá?
para vocês poderem entender, que não é
difícil, gente. Pera aí, deixa eu entrar
numa outra conta aqui.
Vou entrar no YouTube.
Deixa eu fazer o login aqui porque eu tô
deslogado.
Será que é esse aqui? Acho que é.
É essa senha mesmo, que eu tenho um
monte de conta no Google. Às vezes eu me
confundo aqui. Bem, deixa eu dividir a
tela com vocês aqui.
Deixa eu trocar a tela.
Pera aí que eu tô um pouco confuso aqui
de mudar a tela.
Colocar stop screen. Ah, sim. Stop
screen. Share screen.
Ah,
deixa eu
Chrome, ver se eu acho aqui. Cadê a
janela do Chrome? Achei. Pronto. Vamos
lá.
Eu tô aqui, certo, numa outra conta
minha aqui, ó. Eu vou procurar aqui o
meu canal,
o outro canal,
ó.
Tá vendo aqui? Inscrever-se. Eu não tô
me me autosseguindo.
Eu sou um corno mesmo. Eu não tô me
autosseguindo agora. Tô inscrito, tá?
Agora aqui.
Agora eu vou entro aqui na ó, seja
membro aqui, ó. Seja membro. Deixa eu
colocar a tela inteira aqui. Pera aí.
Tela inteira. Pronto.
Seja membro, tá? Ó, cliquei aqui, já
aparece aqui o vídeo extras mais
WhatsApp ou estudos avançados. É só
escolher aqui, ó, estudos avançados,
seja membro. É só clicar aqui, tá bom?
Deu para entender? Beleza,
ficou claro?
Ficou claro, Antônio,
me diz se você entendeu.
Fegando sugere valores da LTanina.
Lteanina é 200 mg, duas a três vezes.
Pode até chegar até quatro vezes ao dia,
tá? Cavac 10. Cavac 10 teoricamente é
uma cozema que é 10 o bquinol de
biodisponibilidade mais alta. Então você
poderia est trabalhando com doses
menores aí em torno de 50 a 200 mg por
dia. Alfalipúrico é 200 mg duas vezes ao
dia. No máximo é 600 mg por dia para ser
tomado antes de dormir para auxiliar
essa questão de padrão num dipper. Já
dei as doses aí, tá?
Quais os assuntos mais falados no
congresso? Boa pergunta.
Eu vou ter que olhar isso com calma
porque eu fiquei mais conversando com o
colega do que vendo aula lá. Eu fiz
muito network que não não vi muita aula
lá não.
Bem, pessoal, Antônio Renato, você tá
aí, eh, você entendeu como é que faz
para mudar lá a categoria?
Entendeu ou não?
Eu apareço e não aparece. Eu já sou
membro.
Dra. Ana Paula, você está? Porque Dra.
Paulo, ela estava também no no no outro
grupo e ela fez o upgrade, ela conseguiu
fazer e a Dra. Ana Paulo não é assim
tão,
digamos assim, proficiente com
computador. Você pode explicar para ele
o que que você fez, Ana Paula?
Eu
não sei se ela tá na live ainda.
Não, ela tá sim, porque ela mandou
mensagem agora 8:11
porque ela tava no grupo, depois ela fez
upgrade. Eu acho que ela não teve
dificuldade para fazer. Ó,
aí, ó. Aí, Antônio, eu te mostrei agora
como é que faz. Eu aperto e dá uma
aparece. Eu não sei.
Mais do que eu já mostrei como é que
faz, eu não consigo mostrar, entendeu?
Aí, ó, recebi algumas horas depois um
e-mail do YouTube.
Reinicia o seu YouTube fora da live.
Como é que é reiniciar o YouTube? Eu não
entendi isso não.
Eu já sou da categoria anterior e não
muda. Eu não sei, sinceramente. Eu eu
teria que fazer uma simulação
do que você tá vendo.
Fazer o seguinte, eu vou fazer isso
agora. Vou vou fazer essa emulação aqui.
Eu vou eu vou assinar eu mesmo aqui e
vou ver se eu consigo fazer o upgrade,
tá? Vamos lá. Vamos dividir a tela de
novo. Vamos lá.
Vamos lá.
Seja membro. Eu vou vai deixar gravado
isso aqui. Se alguém me perguntar de
novo, vai tá gravado isso aqui no na
live, ó. Seja membro,
ó. Cliquei primeiro no no primeiro
grupo.
Vamos lá.
Tem que fazer a compra aqui.
Pera aí que eu não sei se vai aparecer
dado sensível meu aqui. Deixa eu parar
de temporariamente de de apresentar
aqui. Pera aí,
pera aí.
Ah, eu não sei se vai aparecer. Tá
pedindo um código de segurança do meu
cartão de crédito. Aqui eu volto a
apresentar quando eu tiver colocado o
código de segurança. Me dá só um
instante.
Eu vou fazer exatamente como você fez.
Eu vou primeiro eh me inscrever no grupo
mais barato, depois eu vou pro outro.
Pera aí,
deixa eu achar o código de segurança
desse cartão aqui.
Não sei se é esse aqui. Confirma.
Pode ser que ele não vá aceitar isso
aqui. Vamos ver. Pronto, ó. Deixa eu
voltar a tela aqui agora.
Pronto.
Ó, ó que tá aparecendo aqui. É um prazer
ter você como membro. Conheço seus
benefícios, tá? Então, eu estou agora
como membro. Ó, ó, ó. Aqui, ó. Fazer
upgrade.
Fazer upgrade aqui, ó. Tu tu tu.
Ó, ó, ó, ó o botão aqui. Ó o botão aqui,
Antônio Renato.
Fazer upgrade. Tá aqui aparecendo para
mim já aqui, ó, ó, ó.
Vou clicar aqui, ó. Upgrade. Aí aparece
aqui, ó. Ó, estudos avançados.
Vou fazer upgrade, ó. Mudar nível. Ó, ó.
Pronto. Atualize sua assinatura.
Ararará.
Ó. Fazer upgrade. Fazer upgrade. Ó.
Pronto.
Fiz em tempo real. Agora tô no nível
dois. Estudos avançados. Pronto. Não é
possível, gente.
Mais fácil que isso, eu não sei.
Entendeu? Tô mostrando aqui em tempo
real.
Não é
belê
belê.
Então é isso.
Seja bem aí, ó. Agora eu sou o mais novo
membro do do meu grupo aqui, ó. Ó, eu
sou o mais novo membro da meu grupo, ó.
Tá certo, ó. Tá aqui, ó. Tá vendo?
Olha só.
H,
isso. Revejam as lives anteriores.
Revejam as lives anteriores.
Beleza, pessoal? Podemos encerrar já.
Muito ob T novo lá. Você viu o que eu
fiz aqui, Antônio Renato? Tu viu os
passos que eu fiz? Você você veja o
vídeo que tá gravado, tá bom?
Bem, desculpem as brincadeiras aí. Um
grande abraço para vocês. Até para quem
for do grupo de estudos avançados. Até o
próximo domingo. Tchau, pessoal. Beijo
no coração de vocês.